face à un arbre malade un scientifique
est un peu comme un médecin devant son
patient il essaie de comprendre quel mal
l'affect et déjà des diagnostics ont pu
être posées dans le cas de phénomènes
graves comme l'épidémie de la tordeuse
de l'épinette ou encore celle du
dendroctone du pin dans l'ouest du
canada et justement dans cette région
une autre essence d'arbre est en déclin
mais les chercheurs n'arrivent pas à
comprendre exactement pourquoi
[Musique]
cela m'a beaucoup d'amour et beaucoup de
joie c'est un grand plaisir
[Musique]
quand je donne le dernier coup et
finalise l'oeuvre et lorsque je la donne
à quelqu'un
l'expression que je reçois c'est comme
une thérapie
dans son atelier maxicheque ait sculpte
une grande porte
c'est une oeuvre qui représente son
peuple de l'île de vancouver mais aussi
la force de cette nature
[Musique]
il y à une épaule a
fait il ya un visage sur le 12 les
polars qui représente la force winter
comme tous les artistes sculpteurs
autochtones de colombie britannique max
jica et utilise deux essences d'arbres
pour les gros totem l'emblématique cèdre
rouge
pour des objets tels les masques ou bien
cette porte il utilise le cyprès de
notre cas une essence à grande valeur
culturelle pour les premières nations
c'est un bois de très grande qualité
il est plus dur que le cèdre rouge et
surtout plus dense c'est parfait pour ce
genre de sculptures
et lorsque vous travaillez le bois
il y à son odeur beaucoup plus forte que
celle du cèdre rouge
on trouve du si près de nous deux cas
dans les hauteurs de la chaîne côtière
du sud est de l'alaska jusqu'à l'origan
au beau milieu de sa distribution à
bella coola reach the world un autre
sculpteur veut nous montrer ses arbres
s'il peut nous pointer ces arbres qui se
trouve tout en haut de la montagne c'est
qu'ils sont malades
je peux voir les cimes des cyprès de
notre cas
on les voit bien parce qu'elles sont
mortes c'est bien visible
quand on voit une sim blanche je peux
dire que c'est ainsi près de nous il
[Musique]
ya plus d'arbres malades qu'avant
vous pouvez également voir la différence
de couleur il meurt à petit feu mais
nous ne savons pas de quoi
non
et
ça ça fait un beau ça lui bien droit
dans la forêt du mont cypress tout juste
au nord de vancouver le biologiste
richard hamelin constate que le déclin
du cyprès de notre cas est bien réelle
c'est quand même assez généralisé ont
leur tour par exemple le long de la côte
on leur trouvera degois aux états unis
évidemment en alaska où ça causait
beaucoup de problèmes donc ça fait une
centaine d'années quand même qu'on
observe le dépérissement mais depuis les
années 80 c'est en augmentation
[Musique]
donc ça c'est vraiment le symptôme
classique l'heure où on a
le feuillage qui changent de couleur va
mourir et puis ça ça peut causer la
mortalité des branches
donc ici par exemple cette branche là le
feuillage est d'à peu près tout tombait
donc cette branche avait probablement
mourir et puis
plusieurs de ses branches leur vont
probablement subir même ça quand ça se
passe à me après année ben on a des
arbres sont vraiment stressé qui sont
plus capables de de récupérer
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui explique ce déclin
richard hamelin et bon nombre de ses
collègues tentent d'élucider ce mystère
près de prince rupert vanessa comeau
fait partie de cet effort de recherche
elle récolte des données qui permettent
d'analyser l'hypothèse numéro un de ce
déclin les changements climatiques
[Musique]
nous faisons ici un inventaire de l'état
actuel du cyprès de notre cas
nous mesurons tous les arbres matures
notons ceux qui sont morts et ceux qui
sont en déclin à m nous voulons
documenter ces arbres ceux en santé et
sur des claques nous analysons tous
jusqu'aux racines
un certain nombre d'études ont démontré
que les racines du si près de nous tous
cas sont beaucoup moins tolérantes au
gel et au dégel sur le permis
on a vu sur le terrain que le cyprès a
des racines fine plus profond donc
beaucoup plus vulnérables aux
changements de température qui
surviennent durant l'hiver en raison des
changements climatiques
pour y voir plus clair l'équipe récolte
des extraits de racine d'arbre qui
seront envoyés en laboratoire pour
analyse
puisque les racines fines sont les plus
vulnérables au gel dégel elles sont un
élément clé à étudier pour comprendre ce
déclic
à l'université de la colombie
britannique
l'équipe de richard hamelin reçoit ses
racines pour le chercheur il existe une
autre hypothèse qui mérite d'être
étudiée celle de la présence d'un
pathogène depuis quelques années on
travaille à des endroits comme raï de
gouaille par exemple où on trouve
beaucoup de déclin du cyprès de notre
cas le seul endroit où bay a pas
beaucoup de neige à peu près pas de
neige puis repas souvent le gel il ya
aussi des des patterns convoi dans la
mortalité qui nous dit par exemple des
arbres qui m'aura regroupement ça plus
l'air d'un effet de contagion que
l'effet climatique
mais pour confirmer cette hypothèse le
processus est long et fastidieux
une fois qu'on a nos racines on est
capable d'extraire l'adn de ces racines
là on va faire nos analyses génomiques
après ça on va essayer de départager nos
adn dans le temps nos échantillons voici
la pêche aux pathogènes ensuite c'est de
dire d'essayer d'identifier
est-ce qu'on a un pathogène qui cause la
maladie puis qu'est ce que ça donnait
des résultats de pca
il reste des bouts de ficelle pas
attaché que nous on essaie d'aller
d'aller attaché là donc on est positif
là pour les chercheurs il est évident
qu'une multitude de facteurs affectent
le cyprès de doute qu'à trouver les
causes de ce déclin leur prendra encore
beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
le climat fragilise un arbre celui ci
devient plus susceptibles aux agents
pathogènes le climat a un impact
important sur la distribution des agents
pathogènes il est difficile pour le
moment de savoir comme un pathogène
pourrait réagir aux changements de
température ou à des hivers plus au
point mort entre
mille façons pour un pathogène de tuer
larmes les pathogènes peuvent tuer les
armes par les racines par la tige par
les aiguilles par le système vasculaire
à l'intérieur de l'arbre qui
transportent l'eau c'est un peu le défi
d'identifier et de diagnostiquer ce qui
tue les arbres et puis c'est pour ça
qu'on ne peut on n'a pas encore été
capable d'identifier la cause du déclin
du cyprès de notre corps
[Musique]
dans cette quête scientifique
il y a peut être une évidence
les activités humaines de toutes sortes
n'aide en rien le cyprès de notre cas je
pense que quand les changements
climatiques les espèces exotiques la
récolte et le reboisement c'est tout ce
site où des changements dans la forêt
qu'on impose que l'activité humaine
impose qu'ils ont un impact sur la santé
des forêts donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment être aux aguets dans les années
à venir pour voir si c'est la confluence
de ses impacts là donc je pense qu'on
peut aller vers une situation rama
vraiment inquiétante
le cyprès de notre coeur est en déclin
du train le cèdre rouge est aussi en
déclin car on le coupe trop oui pourquoi
avons nous besoin d'apprendre au thym et
laurier redonner à cette nature un
incapable
nous ne prenons qu'un seul arbre ne
prenons pas la forêt entière d'un coteau
parce qu'elle est là cette forêt n'est
pas à moi elle est là pour mes enfants
leurs enfants et leurs enfants nos
ancêtres ont toujours dit nous ne
possédons pas cette nature nous
appartenons à celle ci et nous devons
l'occuper sans la détruire
[Musique]